[Musik]
hallo und herzlich Willkommen zu ZDF
heute live ja wir sind heute etwas
später für euch da als sie das
vielleicht gewohnt seid und zwar weil in
den USA gerade etwas Historisches
passiert die ehemalige US-Präsident
Donald Trump muss gleich in Washington
vor Gericht erscheinen wieder einmal es
ist die dritte strafrechtliche Anklage
und die mit Abstand schwersten Vorwürfe
bisher gegen Trump es geht unter anderem
um wahlbeeinfassung Wahl Beeinflussung
schwieriges Wort und den Sturm auf das
Kapitol im Januar 2021 allein in diesem
Verfahren drohen Trump bis zu 20 Jahre
Haft und trotzdem will Trump im
kommenden Jahr wieder Präsident werden
heute bzw jetzt gleich soll er vor einem
Bundesgericht in Washington DC
erscheinen da soll die Anklage gewesen
werden Trump muss dafür vor Ort sein und
wir fragen uns was bedeutet dieses
Verfahren für seine
Präsidentschaftskandidatur und musste er
trotz einer Verurteilung wieder
Präsident werden und was heißt das für
die Demokratie in den USA und auch für
die internationalen Beziehungen darüber
spreche ich gleich mit der
deutsch-amerikanischen
Politikwissenschaftlerin Katherine
Klüver ashbrook und mit unserem
Korrespondenten Elma teven der für euch
die Ereignisse vor Ort verfolgt wenn ihr
jetzt das Gefühl habt bei diesen ganzen
Ermittlungen gegen Trump so langsam den
Überblick zu verlieren dann nutzt sehr
gerne die Möglichkeit hier im Stream
Fragen zu stellen oder ihr könnt auch
einfach gerne eure Gedanken zum Thema
mit uns teilen und zwar einfach direkt
in den Kommentaren wenn ihr mögt oder
ihr schickt uns die Fragen oder Gedanken
gerne direkt an die Mailadresse die
eingeblendet seht die lautet ZDF heute -
live at zdf.de so wir wollen uns jetzt
einmal aktuell einen Überblick
verschaffen da sehen wir auch schon die
Live Bilder vom Gericht in Washington DC
wie da die Situation derzeit ist und
dafür würde ich jetzt gerne einmal
sprechen mit unserem korresponden ten
da ist er hallo Elmar grüß Dich
hallo grüß Dich nach Deutschland
nimm uns gerne einmal mit wir haben
jetzt gerade schon ein bisschen Bilder
gesehen demonstrierende vor Ort wie ist
die Lage ist Trump noch auf dem Weg oder
ist er tatsächlich schon da
nein er ist da er ist im Gebäude
angekommen wir haben vorhin die Bilder
gesehen wie er vom Flughafen hier in
Washington aus mit einem motorconvoi
gebracht worden ist in die Innenstadt er
ist durch den Tunnel gefahren und dann
eben in einem hinter oder an einem
Hintereingang dieses Gerichtsgebäudes
heran wir rechnen nicht unbedingt damit
dass wir ihn wirklich zu sehen bekommen
also zunächst mal nur die Fahrzeuge und
wenn hinterher alles erledigt ist wird
er vielleicht auf dem gleichen Weg
wieder so verschwinden es gibt
mindestens mal dann Zeichnungen aus den
aus der Verhandlung selber oder der
Anhörung heute vor Gericht und wir haben
natürlich hier vor diesem
Gerichtsgebäude ein riesiges Medien
Getümmel das sind ich würde mal sagen
hunderte von Journalisten insgesamt da
die hier aufgebaut haben es haben sich
aber natürlich auch Trump Anhänger und
Trump Gegner hier schon versammelt
gleich gegenüber wir können es leider
gerade nicht zeigen aber man hört es
vielleicht stehen Trump Befürworter die
der Meinung sind dass dieses Verfahren
im Grunde genommen etwas ist was es nur
in einer Bananen Republik geben dürfte
sie sind sehr lautstark unterwegs es
sind aber wenige weil Washington Geld im
Grunde genommen als ein Pflaster in dem
vor allen Dingen die Demokraten hier
ihre Hochburg haben insofern rechnen wir
damit dass es eher friedlich abgehen
wird aber das hängt ein Stück weit
natürlich auch von dem ab was hinter mir
in diesem Gerichtsgebäude heute
passieren wird
Emma du hast die Anklageschrift im
Vorfeld schon lesen können die ist 45
Seiten stark holen uns gerne einmal mit
ins Boot was steht da drin was wird
Trump im Wesentlichen vorgeworfen
also man könnte es salopp formulieren
nichts anderes als ein Umsturzversuch
gegen die Rechtsordnung der Vereinigten
Staaten von Amerika es wird ihm in vier
einzelnen Anklagepunkten vorgeworfen
eine Verschwörung angeführt zu haben mit
der versucht worden sein soll die Wähler
Amerikas zu entrechten und offizielle
Vorgänge die notwendig sind um einen
neuen prädizität Präsidenten dann ins
anzubringen diese zu ich sag mal unter
Graben zu stoppen und damit im Grunde
genommen Amerika als Rechtsstaat zu
untergraben das wird ihm vorgeworfen
nicht nur ihm alleine es sind in diesem
in dieser Anklageschrift 45 Seiten lang
auch sechs sogenannte mit Verschwörer
aufgeführt die werden zwar Namen
namentlich nicht benannt aber sie werden
beschrieben und so wissen wir dass damit
vor allen Dingen Menschen aus einem
direkten Umfeld Anwälte gemeint sind die
ihn beraten haben darunter Rudi Giuliani
der ehemalige Bürgermeister von New York
aber eben auch ein einführendes
Regierungsmitglied aus dem
Verteidigungsministerium der USA die
sind nicht mit angeklagt sie werden nur
aufgeführt um klar zu machen dass Trump
seine Helfer hatte um eben diesen Betrug
an den Wählern durchzuführen und das vor
allen Dingen dadurch dass er versucht
hat am 6 Januar 2021 Einfluss darauf zu
nehmen dass hier nicht weit von uns ein
paar 100 Meter entfernt im Capitol das
Parlament formell die Bestätigung der
Wahl von Joe Biden zum amerikanischen
Präsidenten bescheinigt das ist
eigentlich ein formaler Vorgang aber er
hat eben an diesem Tag das kann man ja
eindeutig nachweisen seine Anhänger
aufgefordert zum Capitol zu gehen und
die sind dort hingegangen sind
gewalttätig geworden haben das Parlament
gestürmt haben dabei auch Menschen
verletzt einige auch getötet und das
unterm Strich wirft man Donald Trump vor
dass er dies angestiftet hat aber es
geht weiter darüber hinaus dass er eben
auch in verschiedenen Bundesstaaten in
sieben insgesamt versucht haben soll
über seine Anwälte aber auch durch
direkte Einflussnahme das Wahlergebnis
zu verändern obwohl es schon offiziell
zertifiziert war obwohl auch nachgezählt
worden war obwohl Gerichte auch alle
Klagen abgelehnt hatten und deswegen
wird man Donald Trump eben tatsächlich
eine Art Angriff auf die amerikanische
Rechtsordnung vor
du hast es gerade schon gesagt also die
Chancen stehen nicht besonders hoch dass
wir heute von ihm was zu Ohr bekommen er
hat sich aber im Vorfeld auf seiner auf
der von ihm mitbegründeten Plattform
true social geäußert und zwar um gegen
18 Uhr deutscher Zeit da hat er
geschrieben ich übersetze es mal ins
Deutsche ich fahre jetzt nach Washington
DC um zu um verhaftet zu werden weil ich
eine korrupte manipulierte und
gestohlene Wahl angefochten habe es ist
eine große Ehre denn ich werde für euch
verhaftet make America great again
immer er stand ja jetzt schon ich habe
es am Anfang auch gesagt schon mal vor
Gericht zuletzt Mitte Juni in Miami
dabei ging es um die Vorwürfe der
illegalen Aufbewahrung von
Geheimpapieren in seinem Anwesen in
Malaga in Florida Trump selbst schwieg
zu den Anklagepunkten er hat gar nichts
gesagt was erwartest du heute in diesem
Verfahren beziehungsweise während der
Verlesung dieser Anklageschrift von ihm
also wir rechnen damit dass ja auch sehr
zurückhaltend hier sein wird er wird
natürlich auf nicht schuldig plädieren
aber wird nicht inhaltlich anzufangen
hier zum Beispiel die Zuständigkeit des
Gerichtes sind Frage zu stellen oder
möglicherweise zu behaupten dass er doch
tatsächlich im Recht war und dass es
sich hier um meine politische
Verfolgungsjagd handelt das hat er bei
den letzten Vorführungen vor Gericht
nicht gemacht ich glaube es wird ja auch
heute hier nicht machen was ist wirklich
nur ein formales Verfahren das heißt man
wird ihm die Fingerabdrücke abnehmen es
wird festgestellt ob seine Identität
gewährleistet ist er muss dann vor der
Haft Richterin erscheinen die prüft
schlicht und ergreifend ob er nicht
schuldig oder schuldig sagt die Anklage
wird dann in teilnehmen auch verlesen
und dann bestimmt sie im Grunde genommen
das weitere Vorgehen aber sie ist nicht
die Richterin die nachher den Prozess
führen wird das ist eine andere das hier
ist im Grunde genommen also nur ein
formelles Verfahren aber er hat im
Grunde genommen angekündigt dass er
anschließ auf dem Weg zurück am
Flughafen hier in Washington
möglicherweise ein Statement abgeben
will und da rechnen wir natürlich mit
all diesen Vorwürfen die in den letzten
Tagen schon gemacht hat man muss dazu
aber zweierlei sagen das eine ist
natürlich er versucht hier tatsächlich
den Menschen klar zu machen dass der
politische Gegner darauf aus ist ihn
fertig zu machen und er behauptet eben
alles was er getan hätte das ist der
zweite Punkt dass das eben doch legal
gewesen sei aber der Sonderermittler und
vor allen Dingen die geschworenes hat ja
nicht der Sonderermittler alleine über
diese Anlage entschieden sondern ein
eine Jury von Geschworenen hier in
Washington haben darüber abgestimmt die
kamen zu dem Schluss dass ein Präsident
wenn er will auch ein abgewählter
Präsident lügen kann so viel er will er
kann falsch halten behaupten er kann
natürlich selbstverständlich eine Wahl
anfechten dafür gibt es ja den
Gerichtsweg was er nicht tun kann und
nicht tun darf so ist die klare Aussage
auch in der Anklageschrift dass er dann
zur Tat schreitet dass er also versucht
im Grunde genommen sich das Amt zu
stehlen regelrecht das wäre so als wenn
einer sauer ist dass eine Bank die
möglicherweise noch Geld schuldet und
statt dass er dann dieses Geld
einfordert und auf dem Gerichtsweg er
klagt die Bank dann einfach mal ausraubt
also der Rechtsstaat sieht so etwas
nicht vor aber Donald Trump ist sehr
geschickt darin seinen Anhänger und
vorzutäuschen dass es sich hier eben um
einen einseitiges Verfahren gegen ihn
handelt
jetzt ist dieses Verfahren du hast es
jetzt ja auch schon mehrfach gesagt
wirklich ein besonderes eben aufgrund
der Schwere der Vorwürfe auch gegen
Trump laufen ja aber auch schon andere
Verfahren mittlerweile ist angeklagt
wegen 78 Straftaten eine weitere Anklage
kommt wohl bald noch hinzu wir haben
hier mal für euch das alles in dem
kleinen Überblick zusammengefasst
es ist das wohl wichtigste von vier
großen Verfahren gegen Donald Trump im
März hatte ihn der Staatsanwalt von New
York wegen Steuerhinterziehung angeklagt
Trump soll schweige Geldzahlungen an die
frühere Pornodarstellerin stormy Daniels
verschleiert haben
dann die zweite Anklage bei Trump
rechtswidrig geheime staatsdokumente auf
seinem Anwesen in Florida versteckt
hatte die Papiere darunter auch nuklear
Geheimnisse ließ der abgewählte
Ex-Präsident ungesichert Lagern einen
Teil sogar in einem Badezimmer und in
einem Veranstaltungssaal
und dann kommt bald wohl auch die
Anklage von der Staatsanwältin in
Georgia es geht auch um Wahlbetrug und
Erpressung unter anderem bei Trump per
Telefon den Innenminister Georgia's
unter Druck setzte
ich will doch nur
11.780 Stimmen finden so Trump beim
Versuch der Wahl Beeinflussung aus dem
Weißen Haus der Vorfall ist auch Teil
der Anklage in Washington Trump
bezeichnet das Verfahren nun als
illegalen Eingriff in den Wahlkampf
vergleicht es mit Methoden des
Nazi-Regimes nur wenige Republikaner
widersprechen
wir bekommen dazu auch schon bei Youtube
und per Mail angekommentare von euch ich
möchte gerne einmal hier einen mit in
den Stream holen und zwar ist die
Meinung von meine Eule jede Seite
bekommen was er tatsächlich verdient
Emma es geht ja in der Anklage jetzt
auch du hast es schon gesagt und den
Strom aus Capitol am 6 Januar 2021 das
war auf jeden Fall kann man ohne Zweifel
so sagen ein Tag der in die
Geschichtsbücher eingegangen ist und
zwar sind Trump Anhänger in Richtung
Capitol und dann noch ins Capitol
gestürmt als Joe Biden dort als neuer
Präsident bestätigt werden sollte du
warst mit einem Team mit Kollegin von
ZDF an diesem Tag vor Ort beschreib uns
das bitte doch einmal gerne kurz wie
hast du diesen Tag damals erlebt
der Kameramann der damals mit wir haben
mit mir hinter dem Capitol stand so wie
er es jetzt auch gerade hier am
Gerichtsgebäude tut wir waren morgens um
9 Uhr etwa angekommen wir hatten uns
schon gewundert dass so wenig Polizei
vorhanden war direkt an den Stufen des
Capitols das waren hunderte von Trump
Anhängern bereits am Morgen versammelt
einige haben dann natürlich auch die
üblichen Beschimpfungen losgelassen dass
wir Medien doch Feinde des Volkes sein
Volksverräter und dann gegen Mittag
kamen eben hunderte tausende von Trump
Anhänger von dieser Demonstration die
ist hier nah des Weißen Hauses gegeben
hatte zum Capitol stürmten die Stufen
hinauf auch auf der Rückseite des
Capitols wo wir standen und haben dann
eben im Capitol die entsprechenden
Gewalttaten verübt randaliert auf der
Suche nach z.B Nancy Pilot sehen der
Sprecherin des Abgeordnetenhauses oder
Mike Pants im amerikanischen
Vizepräsidentin und als sie dann später
am Nachmittag verjagt wurden mit
Blendgranaten und mit Tränen g kamen sie
raus und zwar in unsere Richtung und
haben dann tatsächlich uns Medien dort
angegriffen unsere Ausrüstung
zerschlagen wir haben Glück gehabt sind
ohne Verletzungen davongekommen aber
unsere Ausrüstung im Wert von 30.000
Dollar wurde damals zerschlagen und das
was uns besonders ich sag mal negativ
beeindruckt ist hat damals ist das die
Menschen mit denen wir teilweise ja
vorher geredet hatten fest davon
überzeugt waren dass sie das absolut
gute tun auch wenn sie eben so eine Art
von Gewalt anwenden einer dieser
Gewalttäter der auch uns angegriffen hat
ist mittlerweile verurteilt
interessanterweise von der gleichen
Richterin die in den nächsten Monaten
den Vorsitz führt über den Prozess gegen
Donald Trump
immer uns erreichen weiter hier fragen
wir Youtube unter anderem der fragt
Johannes zonka der das Verfahren was
jetzt beginnt verringert oder erhöht
dass die Chancen von Trump auf eine
Kandidatur das ist eine Frage die sich
ja viele gerade bewegt
ja also wir sehen im Grunde in den
Umfragen dass das bekannt werden der
Anklage gegen Donald Trump noch mal
Wasser auf seine Mühlen war und
tatsächlich die Zustimmungsrate für ihn
noch erhöht hat also die Umfragen
innerhalb der republikanischen Partei
zeigen deutlich dass er seinen Abstand
auf den zweiten
Präsidentschaftskandidaten wurden die
Sand ist also den hinter ihm liegenden
um auf 37% Punkte ausgebaut hat er liegt
jetzt bei 54% in Umfragen in einem
direkten Vergleich zwischen Präsident
Joe Biden und Donald Trump als mögliche
Widersacher bei der nächsten Wahl können
wir momentan ein Kopf an Kopf Rennen
sehen das sagen jedenfalls die Umfragen
aber das bedeutet nicht dass es am Ende
auch so sein wird denn in diesem
Verfahren werden natürlich diese Beweise
vorgelegt gegen Donald Trump oder der
braucht um Präsident zu werden am Ende
natürlich nicht nur seine ich sag mal
eingefleischten Anhänger sondern er
braucht auch moderate Republikaner er
braucht unabhängige diese bereit sind
für ihn zu stimmen wenn er denn von
seiner Partei tatsächlich zum Kandidaten
ernannt wird beim Wahlparteitag im Juli
nächsten Jahres so und da ist die große
Frage ob nicht viele innerhalb der
republikanischen Partei auch die Nase
voll haben von dem Drama und ihm nicht
zutrauen dass er mit all diesen
Schwierigkeiten und vor allen Dingen
dann auch möglicherweise eine Haftstrafe
in der Lage wäre Amerika als Präsident
zu führen denn auch wenn man das in
Deutschland vielleicht nicht glauben mag
er könnte sogar aus dem Gefängnis heraus
zum Präsidenten gewählt werden und er
könnte möglicherweise dann eben auch
Präsident Amerikas sein
vielen lieben Dank für diese Eindrücke
und Einschätzung im Moment du bist vor
Ort beobachtest die Situation weiter und
wir werden dann im Laufe dieses Streams
gegebenenfalls noch mal zu dir schalten
wenn sich vor Ort was tut vielen Dank
erstmal für den Moment und alles Gute
danke dir
und wir wollen jetzt natürlich auch ich
freue mich sehr dass wir jetzt gleich
jemanden zu Gast haben um uns das
tatsächlich noch mal von der rechtlichen
Seite einschätzen zu lassen mein Kollege
Alternative sind vor Ort hat es
angesprochen das gewisse Dinge z.B das
Trump wohl tatsächlich aus dem Gefängnis
heraus noch Präsident werden könnte aus
deutscher Perspektive ja möglicherweise
etwas seltsam anmuten und da ein
bisschen Sortierung zu kriegen freue ich
mich sehr dass ich jetzt sprechen kann
mit Kirk Junker er ist US-amerikanischer
Rechtswissenschaftler und mir jetzt
zugeschaltet hallo Herr Junker grüße Sie
lassen das gerne tatsächlich einmal der
beginnen damit beginnen was droht Trump
jetzt im Falle einer Verurteilung
ja was in diesem Fall interessant ist
und anders ist als bei den anderen zwei
was wir schon in April unter den Juni
gehabt haben ist das einem von dem ähm
es beschrieben dass er für diese
Aufstand verantwortlich war und wenn
jemand für ein Aufstand verantwortlich
ist denn nach den 14 Novelle der
bundesverfassungen in den USA kann man
nicht ein
öffentliches Amt halten das wurde
bedeuten obwohl wie ihr zuschauen schon
geschrieben haben und außer Täter sind
schon Täter sind schon uns berichtet hat
für andere Straftaten darf er in Prinzip
von Gefängnis noch mal Präsident gewährt
werden nicht wenn er dann ein Aufstand
entweder geplant hat oder in eine
Abstand teilgenommen hat und das ist
etwas anderes jetzt
wie für wie wahrscheinlich halten sie es
denn dass er in diesem Anklagepunkt dann
tatsächlich für schuldig befunden wird
wenn das die entscheidende Frage ist ja
also wir sind haben alle jetzt die der
Herausforderung 45 Seiten zu lesen um
alles zu verstehen was ich merke
juristisch in dieser Anklage ist wie
empfindlich und genau der
Staatsanwaltschaft das beschrieben haben
Beweismittel ist überall drin und das
Beweismittel kommt nicht von Trump
selber oder nicht von selber allein
sondern von den mitbeschwören und wir
wissen wahrscheinlich dass diese Leute
Anwälte sind nur die Giuliani ist
wahrscheinlich eine davon und diese
Beweismittel sehr stark
ob sie das wirklich dann vor dem Gericht
bringen können und benutzen können
müssen wir warten um zu sehen aber ich
glaube sie haben genug Beweismittel wir
haben es wirklich gut dann beschrieben
ja 55 Seiten
uns erreichen wir parallel auch immer
weiter Fragen bei Youtube und zwar
schreibt Justin ich hoffe dass er noch
dieses Jahr ins Gefängnis muss das wäre
ein wichtiges Zeichen gegen Rechts
dieses Verfahren heute wird die Anklage
verlesen für wie wahrscheinlich halten
sie es denn dass dieses Verfahren
zeitnah zu einem Ende kommt ja
ich glaube es gibt viele Leute die
natürlich auch eine Seite wurden sehr
gerne ihnen Gefängnis sehen aber in der
Tat
weniger Leute die zum ersten Mal
verurteilt sind wegen Straftat gehen ins
Gefängnis
das bedeutet wenn eine davon in New York
in in Virginia in Florida in in
Washington
zu Ende gebracht wird und er verurteilt
ist wenn er wie andere Kriminelle
behandelt wäre dann wurde auch nicht in
Gefängnis gehen das bedeutet aber nicht
dass wir nicht verurteilt wird und das
könnte wie schon gesagt hat das könnte
bedeuten er darf dann nicht wieder ein
Bundesamt halten weil er
teilen diese Ausstand genommen hat
eine Frage und für euch auch noch mal
der Hinweis in dieser Stelle schickt uns
wirklich gerne fragen das ist ich kann
es absolut nachvollziehen mag an der ein
oder anderen Stelle wirklich sehr
verwirrend wirken diese ganze Thematik
deswegen nutzt es gerne dass wir hier
die Fragen dass ich die für euch direkt
an unserer Expertin Experten weitergeben
kann eine Frage die uns auch bei Youtube
erreicht hat ist kann es denn sein dass
er wirklich eingesperrt wird also das
Trump im Falle einer Verurteilung
tatsächlich hinter Gittern landet
ja also wie gesagt wahrscheinlich nicht
aber das bedeutet nicht dass er nicht
schuldig verurteilt wird und das ist
schon was ähm weil normalerweise in
kriminelle Prozesse in Strafrecht Leute
die keine kriminelle
Hintergrund haben und zum ersten Mal
verurteilt sind eh nichts Gefängnis
unser reicht noch eine andere Frage von
Birgit Richter bei Youtube das
interessante in Klammern Präsident zu
werden zu können wenn man zu einer
Haftstrafe verurteilt wird heißt das
dass man das passive Wahlrecht in den
USA nicht verliert können Sie dazu was
sagen
ob er selber seine eigene Wahlrecht
verliert
normalerweise nicht es kommt manchmal es
hängt von von Bundesländern ab ob
irgendwo das Länder
wählen darf aber nicht unbedingt nicht
nur weil jemand dann verurteilt ist
okay
eine Frage die hier noch kommt kann
Trump zum Märtyrer werden das ist
wahrscheinlich eine Frage haben Sie
darauf eine Antwort sonst geben wir die
spreche gleich noch mit habe ich am
Anfang schon einmal kurz angekündigt mit
der deutschen amerikanischen
Politikwissenschaftlerin Katherine
Klüver es spukt die würde ich sonst auch
an der Stelle noch mal weitergeben oder
haben sie dazu auch eine Auskunft dass
er tatsächlich zu mehr andere Frage auch
oftmals politisch nicht juristisch ich
würde sagen geben Sie das andere unsere
Kollegen
alles klar eine weitere Frage die uns
erreicht hat die ich dann gerne aber an
sie weitergebe kann Trump seine
Angestellten in den Knast schicken wie
zuvor welche Chancen hätte das das
letzte Mal musste er ja auch nicht
selber einsetzen
nein er kann die nicht schicken
sozusagen aber was interessant ist ist
unter diese Anklage wissen wir dass nach
Verschwörung das bedeutet alle haben
dann zugestimmt etwas kriminell zu tun
also die Tatsache in dem Sinn ist ein
Plan auch wenn sie das nicht dann
durchgeführt haben ist es schon strafbar
und es gibt so viele Beweismittel von
die anderen mit beschwörner dass ich
glaube sie können dann nicht
befreit sie werden dann wahrscheinlich
nachher auch vor dem Gericht gebracht
verstehe ähm ich schaue noch einmal hier
parallel in unsere Kommentare David
Hauck fragt bei Youtube wurde Trump denn
schon einmal rechtskräftig verurteilt
wir haben es jetzt schon gelernt in
diesem Stream gegen ihn laufen mehrere
Verfahren er ist inzwischen angeklagt
wegen 78 Straftaten wurde er ihrer
Kenntnis nach schon einmal rechtskräftig
verurteilt
ja interessant ist auch ich sagte dass
normalerweise beim Strafrecht auch bei
sogenannten normales
straßenstrafrecht straßenkriminelle die
sind nicht beim ersten Verurteilung ins
Gefängnis aber wenn so viele da sind
nach der erste ist Donald Trump dann
nicht mehr jemand der kein kriminelle
Hintergrund hat und dann werden wir
vielleicht bei den zweiten dritten
vierten finden dass er doch vielleicht
ins Gefängnis geschickt werden
gerne noch einmal zum Abschluss wir
haben schon ein bisschen angerissen aber
vielleicht wagen Sie noch einmal eine
Prognose was was glauben Sie wann könnte
dieses Verfahren es scheint ja sehr gut
vorbereitet zu sein die die
Anklageschrift ist 45 Seiten lang was
glauben Sie wann wird dieses Verfahren
zum Ende kommen wenn wir jetzt darauf
schauen im November kommenden Jahres ist
die Präsidentschaftswahl in den USA
glauben sie dass ich das jetzt noch
durch den ganzen Wahlkampf ziehen wird
oder erleben wir möglicherweise vorher
schon ein Ende dieses Verfahrens
alles mit der Trump und seine
juristische Probleme zu tun hat bringt
immer diese Frage vor sollen wir das
schneller machen aus normalerweise weil
ein ein baut am kommt oder wäre es dann
unfair dass wir etwas schneller oder
irgendwie anderes machen würde weil er
einfach nur Donald Trump ist
wir haben schon bei den New York Prozess
gehört es wird wahrscheinlich nur erst
ab Dezember anfangen und ich glaube
diese Zeitfenster ist für
strafrechtliche Prozesse normal ich
würde sagen es wenn wir das benutzen
würden es wird wahrscheinlich erst in
2024 anfangen das ist aber auch nicht
weil er Donald Trump ist sondern weil
normalerweise bei Strafprozess
Prozesse dauert es so laut
würde das denn tatsächlich also wenn wir
jetzt wenn ich sie richtig verstehe dann
ist das sehr wahrscheinlich dass ich
dieses Verfahren in die neue Legislatur
reinzieht und wenn wir jetzt davon
ausgehen nicht davon ausgehen sondern
wenn wir annehmen dass Donald Trump dann
im kommenden Jahr tatsächlich wieder
Präsident würde könnte hätte seine dass
das Amt des Präsidenten könnte ihnen das
dazu befähigen tatsächlich dann Einfluss
auf das dann noch laufende Verfahren zu
nehmen zu seinen Gunsten logischer
Theorien vielleicht unsere politische
wissenschaftliche Kollegin hat auch
einen eine Bericht dafür es geht ein
Theorie was unter George Bush und ähm
eigentlich aber auch seine Vizepräsident
durchgeführt war und das ist ein
sogenannte vor unabhängige sekretiver
und bei solchen Theorie könnte er sagen
man kann nicht etwas gegen hier sei es
zivilrechtlich oder sei es
strafrechtlich in meine Anzeigen bringen
das ist noch nicht getestet aber wir
haben seit Richard Nixon ein just System
doch keiner mehr ist aber noch nicht
getestet
alles klar vielen lieben Dank Kirk
Juncker für diese Einschätzung
US-amerikanischer Rechtswissenschaftler
danke Ihnen dass Sie heute die Zeit für
uns gefunden haben sehr gerne vielen
Dank und wir wollen natürlich jetzt in
diesem Stream auch noch mal sehr gerne
auf die politische Ebene gehen und über
die politischen Auswirkungen sprechen
und auch darüber wie dieses Verfahren
uns ein auch wie auch immer geartete
Ausgang dieses Verfahrens dann auch
Einfluss auf die internationalen
Beziehungen hätte ich freue mich sehr
dass wir darüber jetzt sprechen können
ich habe sie gerade schon einmal
angekündigt mit Katherine Klüver asbrook
dort amerikanische
Politikwissenschaftlerin die wir ich
glaube in Berlin erreichen guten Abend
Frau Klüver danke dass Sie sich die Zeit
nehmen sehr gerne guten Abend
also wir haben schon von deinem Kollegen
MRT Wissen gehört diese ankergeschäft 45
Seiten lang im Wesentlichen geht's um
vier Punkte Behinderung eines
offiziellen Verfahrens Verschwörung zur
Behinderung eines offiziellen Verfahrens
Verschwörung zu Betrug an den USA sowie
Verschwörung um andere an der Ausübung
ihrer verfassungsmäßigen Rechte zu
hindern wenn wir das einmal auf die
größere Ebene heben um was geht es da
tatsächlich im Kern bei dieser Anklage
es geht darum wie ja wie
verteidigungsfähig ist im Grunde
genommen noch die amerikanische
Demokratie an sich wir haben in den vier
Jahren der Trump Art ministration erlebt
wie dieser Präsident Raubbau am System
an sich gebaut hat er hat sich ein
Obersten Gerichtshof zusammengebaut der
nunmehrheitlich konservativ besetzt ist
und der und dann hat gehört Juncker sich
in diese Argumentation noch nicht
reingelehnt aber natürlich wird wenn
sich der Prozess sieht wenn ein Donald
Trump wieder ins Amt gewählt wird wenn
er versucht über verschiedene
Spitzfindigkeiten
quasi seine Immunität zu erzwingen eine
oberster Gerichtshof der so besetzt ist
wir besetzt ist natürlich auch eine
Rolle spielen also im ersten Moment geht
es darum wie funktioniert der
amerikanische Rechtsstaat noch
funktioniert er noch kann er ganz
grundsätzlich bestimmte Prozesse und da
geht's noch mal auch um die
Gewaltenteilung also kann ein
unabhängiger Justizapparat auch zum
Beispiel gegen ein ehemals höchsten
Beamten am Start wenn man so will
vorgehen und das hat natürlich wieder
Auswirkungen auf die Amerikaner an sich
empfinden die ihre Demokratie noch als
funktionsfähig wie gehen sie selber mit
ihrem eigenen Wahlrecht um ist das
Wahlrecht für sie überhaupt noch
glaubhaft und ich glaube allein die
Tatsache dass wir jetzt bei dieser
Anklageschrift sind zeigt doch schon
dass das Wahlrecht an sich und das ist
eben eine Subtext wenn man sich die
45-seitige Anklageschrift noch mal
anschaut oder auch in den Argumenten die
der Sonderermittler noch mal präsentiert
hat hier geht es darum dass die
Amerikaner sehr tiefen Verlust leiden
könnten an dem eigenen Verständnis des
Wahlrechts an der quasi geheimen
gleichen gerechten Wahl wenn dieser
Prozess so nicht durchkommt bzw wenn der
Präsident wenn diese Anklage nicht voll
gehört wird wenn dieser Prozess nicht
voll durchgeführt wird und das ist die
ganz ganz großen Gefahr
uns erreichen wir weiter Fragen bei
Youtube unter anderem fragt Anna m
könnte das Urteil die amerikanische
Gesellschaft noch mehr Spalten in
Klammern Aufstände etc wie ist da ihre
Einschätzung auch mit Blick auf die ja
angespannte politische gesellschaftliche
Lage im Moment
realisierte Gewalt bleibt weiterhin das
hat das sagt das FBI bei jeder Anhörung
und jeder Anfrage bleibt weiterhin ein
ganz die größte Sicherheitsbedrohung im
Grunde genommen für die USA also das ist
und das haben wir natürlich auch bei den
Zwischenwahlen im letzten Jahr zumindest
vermutet dass es auch in einzelnen
Bundesstaaten mitunter eben auch wieder
zu bewaffneten Aufständen kommen würde
das grenzt zu fast einem Wunder dass das
nicht der Fall war denn grundsätzlich
prallen eben zwei Dinge aufeinander
Wissen hat angesprochen die Verfahren
die nun gegen die Teilnehmer des 6
Januars in den verschiedenen
Bundesstaaten in ihren eigenen
Bundesstaaten aber auch in Washington DC
laufen und da hört man immer wieder dass
die Teilnehmer an diesem Aufruhr und der
im Grunde genommen dem Angriff dem
physischen Angriff auf das Herzen der
amerikanischen Demokratie wirklich
geglaubt haben ihn würde umgekehrt ihre
eigenen ihr eigenes Verständnis von
Demokratie gestohlen ihr würde ihnen
würde ihre ihre eigene freie Stimme
gestohlen und die Tatsache solche
grundsätzlichen Verständnislücken in der
amerikanischen Gesellschaft Klassen mal
abgesehen von wirklichen Inhalt schweren
oder Inhalt also wenn es um
Wirtschaftspolitik ginge oder um
Bildungspolitik oder andere thematische
die Tatsache das ist grundsätzlich um
ein Verständnis von Systemarchitektur
geht das ist doch was was sich das lässt
sich in keiner Weise negieren das lässt
sich nicht weg trennen nicht wegdenken
und umgekehrt erhöht ist ganz klar das
Potenzial wieder für politisierte für
radikalisierte Gewalt und
Gewaltausbrüche in den Vereinigten
Staaten das ist klar
dazu fragt
Domi bei Youtube passt sehr gut woran
liegt es dass die Begeisterung für Trump
in den USA wie eine ungeheuer
gefährliche real Satire wird und
anscheinend ist es und es anscheinend so
schwierig ist dem einen Ende zu setzen
und diese ja ich ergänze jetzt diese
sehr weit auseinanderklaffen
möglicherweise wieder zu versöhnen
der das hat im Grunde genommen oder zum
Teil jedenfalls Wurzel in einer
veränderten mediengesetzgebung in den
USA die auf die 80er Jahre unter Ronald
Reagan zurückgeht wo zum Beispiel in
öffentlichen Medien nicht mehr gesagt
wurde es gibt die eine Meinung die
andere Meinung und ganz klar
gekennzeichnet wurde dass es zum
Beispiel nicht um meinungsfernsehen und
Meinung Journalismus gegen sondern das
anfing diese Dinge zu vermischen und
verschwimmen zu lassen gleichzeitig
gegen einen Herr ein Abbau natürlich in
ja der ganz ganz banalen öffentlichen
Bildung wie wie funktioniert ein
regierungs- und Rechtssystem wie soll
ein rechtsapparat funktionieren das
würde immer zum Teil von Bundesstaat zu
Bundesstaat abgebaut wir haben jetzt
gerade wieder ähnliche Fälle in Florida
das führt dazu dass gerade was die
medienspalte Reihe im Land
die Auswirkungen die das auf das Land
gehabt haben und auf das Verständnis
davon wie ein System funktioniert das
ist schon mal die Grundlage auf dem
einen Donald Trump mit jetzt der großen
Lüge wie wir sie inzwischen nennen also
nämlich der Lüge von der empfohlenen
Wahl und von denen quasi gestohlenen
Wahlmännern und und und dass er damit
weiter durchkommt das heißt bis jetzt
glauben über 60 Prozent der
republikanischen Anhänger das in der Tat
Joe Biden nicht rechtmäßig Präsident der
Vereinigten Staaten ist und deshalb
sehen wir eben auch nicht zuletzt jetzt
auch eben unter den paar
protestprotestlern die jetzt quasi
wirklich vor dem Justizgebäude stehen
die haben eben immer testen hat gezeigt
Trump oder death also das ist bis zum
Tod bis zum letzten quasi verteidigen
wollen ihren Kandidaten deren Lüge sie
in Anführungszeichen auf den Leim
gegangen sind und ja man würde meinen
dass durch mediendebatten durch
Diskussionen durch Bildung und so weiter
und so fort sich diese Dinge aushebeln
lassen aber es ist eine enorm großes
Land es ist eine enorm gespaltene Medien
und Informationslandschaft und diese
Prozesse haben sich über die Jahre das
ist nicht ein ein das ist nicht allein
Trump anzuhängen aber dennoch er hat
systematisch weiter an dem Umbau im
System gedreht er hat Richter eingesetzt
die eine bestimmte Logik verfolgen die
zum Teil auf Lebzeiten Lebzeiten ändern
sind das heißt der schleichende Raubbau
und der schleichende Abbau im Prozess
oder eben in dem Konstrukt der
amerikanischen Demokratie den hat Trump
nicht angefangen aber den hat er
beschleunigt und verschärft und will
sich das und das wissen wir weil eine
ein investigative Reportage der New York
Times vor zehn Tagen rauskam auch noch
weiter an diesen Privilegien die ein ein
ja der der Präsidentschaftsamt die
Exekutivgewalt leisten kann da möchte er
weiter am sogenannten tiefen Staat wie
er das weiterhin seinen Anhänger erzählt
abbauen das heißt er möchte sich mehr
möchte mehr Macht auf das Weiße Haus
vereinigen und da sind wir dann schon
wirklich am Anfang eines diktatorischen
Denkens einer exekutiv Diktatur das wäre
ein ja ein komplettes umholen
der
ältesten noch funktionalen Demokratie
auf der Welt
für wie realistisch halten sie es denn
dass er angesichts dieser Anschuldigung
der gegen ihn laufenden Verfahren
tatsächlich dann sozusagen erfolgreich
ins Weiße Haus läuft es gibt jetzt sie
haben gerade eine Recherche der New York
Times zitiert es gibt es gab zuletzt
eine Umfrage der Jörg times die zeigt
das 54 Prozent der Republikaner hinter
Trump stehen man hat also den Eindruck
sie haben es gerade auch schon
angedeutet dieses Verfahren und die auch
schon jetzt laufenden Ermittlung die
nutzen ihm vielleicht sogar mehr als
dass sie im schaden oder
erst einmal in der Tatsache dass er
genügend Geld eintreiben kann um seine
sehr teuren Anwälte zu bezahlen 40
Millionen Dollar haben bereits diese die
quasi die Verteidigung und den Anfänge
der Prozesse zwei davon haben wir
bereits schon angesprochen jetzt geht
dieser los er hat ein neues Anwaltsteam
gerade für diesen Prozess angestellt das
haben hat bereits 40 Millionen Dollar
verschlungen und das und das ist noch
mal eine urige Situation im
amerikanischen System kann er über
Parteispenden bzw über Wahlspenden
finanzieren also da auch da hängen Dinge
im Magen ähm und er schafft es wäre
wiederum dass seine Anhänger das
finanzieren wollen mit der Argumentation
und er hat eben diesen Märtyrer ähm
Kontext für sich gewählt und das
Märtyrer Bild für sich gewählt ich wenn
sie wenn sie mich verfolgen wollen
werden sie als nächstes euch verfolgen
das heißt ähm er er wirft seine Arme
schützend um seine Anhänger und nimmt
sie mit und die sind eben noch zumindest
spendierfreudig genug dass sie ihm
allein im letzten Quartal also in den
letzten drei Monaten noch mal 35
Millionen in die Parteikasse oder in
seine Wahlkampfkasse gespült haben mit
denen er sich dann wieder selbst
finanziert also es ist es ist natürlich
das sind alles Eigenheiten das
amerikanischen Systems das ist urig und
schwierig aber es könnte natürlich so
weit kommen das hat kein Juncker nicht
ganz ausgeführt aber wenn zum Beispiel
dieser Prozess
bis in die ersten Monate eine
amerikanischen Präsidentschaft oder in
die quasi in diesem interregen um Zeit
also in der in die Zeit fallen würde
zwischen November und der amtsannahme im
Januar wenn es in der Zeit z.B einen ja
ein Resultat gäbe in diesem Prozess eher
für schuldig gefunden wurde dann gäbe
z.B noch den Weg über den 25
Verfassungszusatz dann müsste der
Vizepräsident oder die Vizepräsidentin
die dann gewählt worden wäre plus eine
Mehrheit des kabin sich gegen den
Präsidenten Stellen sagen die Verfassung
sowie Mike Pens ist jetzt letzt zuletzt
getan hat damals nicht öffentlich jetzt
aber wohl sehr wohl öffentlich gesagt
hat es kann kein einzelner Mann kein
einzelner Mensch sich über die
Verfassung stellen und wir sprechen dem
Präsidenten die Regierungsfähigkeit auch
das könnte alles noch passieren das
heißt viele viele Dinge sind noch im
völlig unklaren aber das insgesamt ist
zu einer
Gerichtsbarkeit kommen muss sieben Tote
am 6 januar und quasi die amerikanische
Demokratie mit Füßen getreten dass
dieser Prozess bis ins letzte
ausgefochten werden muss das ist glaube
ich für dich Funktionalität die
Integrität aber auch die Rolle Amerikas
in der Welt ganz grundsätzlich wichtig
und das richtige Signal
welche Auswirkungen sind sie denn von
diesen Prozess tatsächlich auch auf die
internationalen Beziehungen und auch
wenn wir nach Deutschland schauen auf
die deutschen Beziehung
erstmal vieles die USA werden jetzt
wieder in einem mediensturm und Sprudel
geraten wie es oft natürlich vor einer
Präsidentschaftswahl ist nämlich eine
völlige Beschäftigung oder einer
jedenfalls mediale Beschäftigung erstmal
mit sich selbst in der Regel spielt
Außenpolitik natürlich in einem
amerikanischen
Präsidentschaftswahlkampf eine ziemlich
untergeordnete Rolle und dennoch haben
wir natürlich einen Krieg mit einem
Herzen Europas einen russischen
Angriffskrieg und wir wollen noch mal
daran erinnern dass der erste
amtsenthebungsprozess für Donald Trump
dass die Substanz dieses
amtsenthebungsprozess die Prozess ist
die Ukraine war er hat versucht
Präsident selenski zu erpressen um
Informationen über den Sohn des jetzigen
Präsidenten Joe Biden heraus zu bekommen
und da auch wurden ihm verschwörerische
Tendenzen gegen sein eigenes Land
vorgeworfen in diesem ersten
Amtsenthebungsverfahren also es ist
keiner Weise wäre nicht gewährleistet
dass gerade das was die westliche
Wertegemeinschaft sagt ich mal denn dann
gehören ja auch Australien und Südkorea
und andere Länder dazu die viel für die
Ukraine tun und leisten dass die das
jetzt die führungskapazität der USA
zumindest eingeschränkt wäre wir können
uns auch vorstellen dass in einem
Wahlkampf ja auch eine beiden
Administration zunächst einmal die
großen Gelder und die große
Unterstützung etwas einfrieren möchte
etwas geringer halten möchte denn große
Wirtschaftsfragen werden diesen
Wahlkampf bestimmen wenn es denn zu
Inhalten kommt wenn ich das ganze
nächste Jahr 2024 eben mit den
juristischen Prozessen eines Donald
Trump aufgesogen wird jedenfalls medial
das heißt natürlich der Blick auf die
großen Probleme die sich jetzt wirklich
stellen die Rolle Chinas in der Welt die
Verhältnisse des Westens mit Autoritäten
Ländern während eine USA in ein quasi
autoritärisches System Abrutschen
könnten nicht sofort über Zeit aber
die Tendenzen sind damit einer zweiten
Präsidentschaft von Donald Trump wäre
eben auch mit dem Ausbau dieser
Tendenzen zu rechnen das hätte natürlich
unglaubliche erderschütternde
Auswirkungen auf die ja auf die
Glaubwürdigkeit die Glaubhaftigkeit des
des westlichen Bündnisses zunächst
einmal aber eben auch auf die
internationale Rechtsstaatlichkeit denn
wir haben ja gesehen in der ersten Trump
hat miristration haben sich die USA
zurückgezogen aus wichtigen Gremien bei
den Vereinten Nationen da stand immer
die Drohung im Raum die USA würden die
NATO verlassen und und und all diese
Dinge sind natürlich immer noch
weiterhin teilen oder möglicher Teil
einer zweiten Trump Präsidentschaft wenn
denn alles normal verlaufen würde also
auf darauf muss ich Europa einstellen da
geht es darum viel mehr Verantwortung
übernehmen zu können militärische Art
finanzieller Art um quasi auch das
westliche wertebündnis weiter zu halten
aber ganz grundsätzlich steht eben
dahinter wenn der Anker der westlichen
demokratischen Weltordnung
Vereinigten Staaten sich langsam bewegen
oder vielleicht auch gar nicht mal so
langsam bewegen zu einer
exekutiv-diktatur also quasi wo mächtige
gesammelt werden in einem Weißen Haus wo
ein demokratischer Prozess nicht mehr
gewährleistet werden kann dann ist das
eine Signalwirkung an die zwei großen
autoritären Mächte nämlich an Russland
und China wir sehen Bewegungen des Iran
in den letzten Tagen auf sich dort
weiter aufzuspielen wir haben die
raketenteste Nordkoreaner stark
beobachtet das heißt dass sich diese
Spaltung zwischen Demokratien und
autoradien erstens nicht nur verfestigt
aber das dann die USA nicht mehr als
bullwerk also nicht mehr als als ja als
als Grenze und nicht mehr als
finanzstark als institutioneller als
glaubhafte glaubwürdige glaubhaftige
Grenze zwischen diesen zwei Systemen
stehen würden und da würde dann
natürlich auch Europa eine ganz ganz
andere Rolle zu kommen als es je
historisch gegeben hat also das sind das
sind vielleicht apokalyptische Skizzen
die ich jetzt hier präsentiere aber sie
sind nicht ganz unrealistisch denn wie
gesagt das wir haben die Beweislage der
ersten Amtszeit Donald Trumps wir haben
den Obersten Gerichtshof besetzt wie er
es ist und wir haben schon einiges
gehört an Plänen die ein Donald Trump
haben könnte in einer zweiten Amtszeit
und die sich auch noch deutlich
verschlimmern könnten wenn er das Gefühl
hat die Schlinge um seinen Hals zieht
sich juristisch so eng das ist quasi
kein ja keine Rolle mehr für die USA auf
der Welt geben kann international geben
kann bzw die USA sich dann in einem
Wahlkampf immer mehr um sich selbst
kümmern werden muss und wieder um dieses
um ja also wie hat Joe Biden das
ausgedrückt um den Kampf zwischen der
Dunkelheit und dem dem hellen und in dem
Sinne dem Kampf zwischen einem Abgleiten
in eine zunehmende
motivdiktatur versus bei dem
Aufrechterhalten dessen was man noch als
Demokratie verstehen kann frau Klöwer es
geht also Sie haben es gerade gesagt
düsteres Szenario es geht tatsächlich
bei diesem Verfahren um sehr viel wir
haben jetzt gerade noch mal die
Livebilder sehen können vom Gericht in
Washington DC Trump ist offenbar durch
die Tiefgarage ins Gerichtsgebäude
gefahren wir haben ihn nicht mehr zu
Gesicht bekommen was da drin passiert
können wir im Moment nicht
nachvollziehen weil im Gerichtssaal
keine Presse zugelassen ist wir werden
das natürlich hier weiter für euch
beobachten ich würde Ihnen noch gerne
einmal am Ende jetzt unsere Streams eine
Frage weiterreichen die kommt von
jetzt habe ich sie von
mozzi ist sie ist Lack fragt bei Youtube
könnten Sie sich vorstellen sie haben es
gerade schon über die möglicherweise
dann neue Rolle der Europäer gesprochen
könnten Sie sich vorstellen dass die
deutsche Gesellschaft auch so etwas
wieder reinfällt also das durch das was
gerade in den USA passiert
möglicherweise auch Demokratien die wir
hierfür sehr stabil halten ins Wanken
kommen
das unsere Demokratie nicht bis ins
Letzte stabil ist das sehen wir an den
Umfragewerten für die AFD das sehen wir
an der Tatsache dass eine AFD eine
Regierungsbeteiligung
als mögliche
Zukunftsszenarien skizzieren das sehen
wir daran wie wenig zum Teil unsere
demokratischen Parteien einer AFD nicht
nur inhaltlich aber auch im Stil
entgegenzusetzen haben das ist natürlich
wir haben besonders meine Generation hat
sich damals geschworen dass wenn sowas
wieder passiert wir da nicht nur
hinschauen sondern dass wir eine Antwort
haben und dass wir ein nie wieder auch
international durchsetzbar ist
durchsetzbar machen können und wir haben
an den ersten vier Jahren der Trump hat
Migration gesehen wie wenig wir auf
solche Angriff auf die Normen in der
internationalen Politik aber eben auch
auf das ja zwischenstaatliche Verhältnis
vorbereitet waren besonders Deutschland
wurde ja unter Donald Trump quasi zur
Angriffsfläche umgekehrt dürfen wir
diesen Fehler einfach nicht wieder
machen es gilt da darum bei uns
natürlich unsere Institutionen unsere
Demokratie zu stärken wir haben im
nächsten Jahr Europawahl da wählen und
deutsche das erste Mal ab 16 das ist
eine wahnsinnig wichtige Verantwortung
das muss allen Wählern allen jungen
Wählern klar sein das ist hier geht
darum geht für Demokratie für
Rechtsstaatlichkeit und für ein System
einer Friedensordnung de facto auch wenn
wir in der die Ukraine dabei
unterstützen ihre Unabhängigkeit wieder
zu erlangen dass wir eine
Friedensordnung unterstützen müssen die
quasi unseren Wohlstand die unsere ganze
Weltordnung zementiert hat und das ja
und das war mit dem
Politikwissenschaftler dem französischen
Politikwissenschaft
zu fassen das muss ein Pestizid das
jeden Tag sein also jeden Tag muss man
sich neu zum demokratischen System
bekennen und umgekehrt muss Deutschland
nun schauen mit welchen Partnern in den
USA man weiterhin gut zusammenarbeiten
kann selbst wenn ähm ja ist nun eine
politische nabelbeschau geben wird über
dieses Wahljahr 2024 eine Konzentration
auf den die Nachhaltigkeit der
amerikanischen Demokratie ist muss
natürlich weiterhin Politik gemacht
werden es muss weiterhin die
internationale Ordnung aufrechterhalten
werden und da muss Deutschland schnell
und sichere Partner für suchen die gibt
es die gibt es im Kongress die gibt es
in auf bundesstaatlicher Ebene und man
muss zu einer neuen Strategie kommen im
Umgang mit den USA aber auch in der
partnerschaftsfindungen der Welt dabei
ist die Bundesregierung geht sie
ziemlich Behinderte vor aber das muss
noch deutlich ausgebaut werden und
umgekehrt wird es darum gehen dass wir
alle weiterhin zur Wahl gehen und unser
Wahlsystem unsere
wahlrechtsmöglichkeiten zum vollsten
nutzen
ein starker Appell von der deutschen
amerikanischen Politikwissenschaftlerin
Kathrin klüger vielen Dank für die
ganzen Informationen und Einschätzung
heute Abend hier bei ZDF heute live
danke Ihnen sehr gerne und wir würden
jetzt gerne noch einmal schauen mit euch
nach Washington DC zum Gerichtsgebäude
da steht's nach wie vor mein Kollege MRT
Wissen der für uns die Situation
beobachtet immer was hat sich seit
unserem Gespräch wir sprachen vor
ungefähr 35 Minuten was tut sich bei dir
aktuell vor Ort
ja Donald Trump ist jetzt im
Gerichtssaal er ist vor einigen Minuten
dort hineingekommen hat den
Sonderermittler Jack Smith mit keinen
Blick gewürdigt er ist jetzt formell
verhaftet aber das Verfahren was jetzt
eben abrollt ist ein ich sag mal reine
Formsache es wird die Anklage verlesen
er muss dann schuldig oder nicht
schuldig plädieren ihr habt Richterin
wird entscheiden inwieweit sie
möglicherweise
Untersuchungshaft anordnet aber
eigentlich rechnet damit niemand weil
wenn Sie das täte könnte das tatsächlich
am Ende die Anhänger von Donald Trump
noch weiter aufstacheln wird auch nicht
davon ausgegangen dass es Flucht Gefahr
für ein ehemaligen Präsidenten der
Vereinigten Staaten gibt und Donald
Trump hat angekündigt dass er hinterher
am Flughafen hier in washing noch eine
Pressekonferenz ergeben wird und wir
rechnen damit dass das Wohlverhalten
dass wir jetzt gerade im Gerichtssaal
erlebt haben sind keine Kameras erlaubt
aber wir hören aus dem Gerichtssaal dass
das so abgelaufen ist dass dieses
Wohlverhalten sich dann schnell wieder
ändert dass er dann auf den
Sonderermittler schimpfen wird dass er
das Ganze eben als eine politische
Verfolgungsjagd darstellen will und das
werden wir dann nachher sehen wenn er am
Flughafen tatsächlich angekommen ist
sind live vor Ort vielen Dank wir
bleiben natürlich an dieser Sache für
euch weiter dran werden das weiter
beobachten auch hier in zukünftigen
Streams die wir machen wenn ihr dazu
aktuelle Infos noch haben wollt und die
in dem Moment dann nicht hier bei uns
bekommt dann schaut einfach sehr gerne
vorbei bei der in der ZDF heute App da
findet ihr natürlich immer aktuelle
Nachrichten soweit der Stream zu dem
Auftakt des Verfahrens gegen Donald
Trump macht's gut danke fürs zuschauen
und bis bald